вітаємо Ласкаво просимо до програми
Європа У фокусі з вами я ліс шу у
Німеччині повідомлення про таємну
зустріч правих екстремістів які планують
депортувати людей з іноземним
походженням викликають масові
хвилювання у таких містах як Кельн
Мюнхен лепциг і Берлін сотні тисяч людей
виходять на демонстрації посилаючи
чіткий сигнал проти расизму і ненависті
які поширюють праві екстремісти і
популісти мовчазна більшість подає свій
голос закликаючи до відкритого
суспільства і демократії в
Німеччині пік масової міграції в
Німеччині припав на 2015й рік коли майже
мільйон людей були зареєстровані як
біженці відтоді суспільство і політики
розділилися в думках щодо того як
найкраще поводитись із біженцями Та
мігрантами це питання породило
популістів які бачать в іноземцях
загрозу одне баварське село демонструє
інший шлях громада гебертсгаузена
зробила все можливе щоб якнайшвидше
інтегрувати біженців джало чернор
скористався цією схемою почувається тут
у Німеччині як удома
[музика]
гебертсгаузен муніципалітет в окрузі
дахау в Баварії не схожий на інші міста
Німеччини місто Що налічує усього 6 000
мешканців приймаєть більше біженців та
мігрантів ніж офіційно вимагається і
робить це добровільно нові робочі руки
потрібні як і зазвичай Петер Барт
заходить у колишню лікарню де живе
багато людей якими він
[музика]
опікується бракти ти ще тут я мушу знати
щодо чого ось ц
заявка ми все вирішили до вихідних це
для декого Іншого не для
тебе Так це може
спрацювати мова про послідку на
проживання для
тебе Я впевнений що ти впораєшся з цим
сам барти консультує що до подачі
документів організовує мовні курси і
заохочує новоприбулих якнайшвидше
знаходити роботу за його словами
вивчення мови та пошук роботи це ключ до
успішної інтеграції моя мета направити
людей на правильний шлях щоб їм тут жило
все
добре І це робота якій немає
кінцяжало чернор отримав саме таку
допомогу він родом із сєра Леоне Західна
Африка і приїхав до Баварії 10 років
тому він закінчив школу і отримав
професійно-технічну освіту зараз працює
в агентстві з працевлаштування на
тимчасовій роботі чернор хотів би
залишитися в Німеччині та отримати
громадянство і він наполегливо над цим
працює
усе залежить від мотивації та
усвідомлення того що ти хочеш залишитися
у Німеччині усе починається з бажання
вивчити мову потім піти до школи а потім
почати розмовляти
німецькою вчити мову дійсно дуже важко
але якщо ви будете продовжувати і
продовжувати ви зможете потроху
розмовляти з людьми і це дуже добре
мюнхенське агентство тимчасової
зайнятості в якому працює чернор
спеціалізується на працевлаштуванні
біженців імігрантів у компаніях Баварії
але не у всіх із них є такий ентузіазм і
мотивація як у
чернора із заявок які ми отримаємо за
тиждень скажімо лише близько 10%
задовольняються але в гебертсгаузені цей
відсоток приблизно у вісім разів більший
чому так місцева громада не бачить у
біженцях і мігрантах загрозу а радше
шанс для місцевого бізнесу якому вкрай
потрібні працівники Малі підприємства
такі як міська пекарня гостро потреб
їхньої
допомоги країна залежить від праці
імігрантів але консервативний мер із
християнсько-соціального Союзу хотів би
щоб федеральний уряд організував усе це
краще ніж було
досі Ми навіть не можемо розрізнити хто
в'їжджає в Країну У пошуках прихистку А
хто приїжджає на підставі іміграції і це
наш найбільший конфлікт ми досі
намагаємося розглядати всіх під
заголовком при
У мене все чудово Дякую А як ви усе
гаразд петере повертаємося до притулку
для біженців Петер Барт часто стає
свідком того що лише деякі з тих хто
приїжджає сюди мають реальні шанси на
отримання прихистку на підставі того що
їхньому життю загрожує небезпека у їхніх
рідних країнах їм важко знайти роботу
поки розглядається їхнє прохання про
надання
прихистку боюсь він англійською теж не
говорить завдяки сній особистій
підтримці та чудовим контактам у районі
гебертсгаузен барту вдається знайти
роботу для людей із усього
світу Я вважаю що якщо люди з якоїсь
причини опинилися тут ми маємо зробити
все можливе щоб інтегрувати їх і
прийняти лікарня неподалік встановлює
свою власну політику вона набирає і
наймає кваліфікований персонал і усього
світу як наприклад хаміда яфея новде і
зрану він легально в'їхав до Німеччини
за робочою візою у тегарані чоловік уже
працював медбратом і вивчив німецьку
мову протягом останнього року він будує
тут своє нове
життя Я думаю що найважливіша частина -
Це звісно
мова Я хотів би покращити свої мовні
здібності адже Це дало б мені можливість
розширити свої знання та професійні
навички
Привіт Мессі я чимось можу
допомогти тобі приходили якісь листи
колишній менеджери з нерухомості не
сумнівається що в майбутньому Усе більше
людей переїжджатимуть до Німеччини ми
більше не можемо ухилятися від
відповідальності і будувати стіни не
пускати людей а потім вдавати що у нас
немає жодних проблем як на мене кожен
хто дивиться на це так
божевільний Петер Барт радить сприймати
нинішню ситуацію як можливість ті хто
приїжджає до гебертсгаузена отримують
допомогу необхідну для пошуку роботи та
інтеграції і
гебертсгаузен може стати прикладом для
всієї
Німеччини у той час як країни досі
сперечаються щодо того скільки мігрантів
вони повинні впустити по всій Європі
стає все більш очевидним що весь
Континент стикається з дедалі більшим
дефіцитом робочої сили Що допомогло
Александру мацоті швидко знайти роботу в
Австрії Він покинув свою рідну бразилію
щоб почати нове життя в Альпах робота у
жвавому ресторані у ціілерталі доволі
важка але і дуже
приємна Міша напевно не пам'ятає Як це
жити у мирній
країні як і він мільйони дітей що
ростуть у пережили травми і втрати яких
жоден Батько не побажав би своїй
дитині ось уже майже два роки тому
Українські війська захищають свою країну
від повномасштабного вторгнення Путіна У
той час як солдати борються за свободу
мирні жителі борються за хоч який спокій
для
дітей два роки війни і кінця їй не
видно ми любимо знайомити вас із
європейцями які йдуть за своєю
пристрастю незважаючи ні на що цей
чоловік точно підходить під цей опис тут
у морі на своєму човні в його улюбленому
місті жозеп паскуаль протягом десятиліть
він щотижня виміряє температуру
Середземного моря йому за це не платять
але дані які він збирає біля узбережжя
лєстратіт насправді дуже корисні для
дослідників для кліматичної політики і
для тих чиї засоби до існування залежать
від риби
[музика]
ще тільки звітанок але жозеп паскуаль
уже в
дорозі Він виходить у
море 73річний чоловік збирає дані про
погоду на суші та у
воді
Я використовую спеціальні термометри які
можна опустити в
море Приблизно через 5 хвилин вони
перевертаються і показують температуру
на
глибині паскуаль знає все про море і про
вимірювання понад півстоліття топограф
синрибалки займаються своїм хобі біля
узбережжя Лер на північному сході
Іспанії якщо погода дозволяє Він
виходить у море двічі на тиждень аби
задокументувати температуру води у
Середземному морі
це моє життя моє
місце це майже як
наркотик з самого дитинства мене це
захоплює головним чином тому що таких
даних не існувало коли мені було 15 чи
років
дійшовши до першої точки вимірювання
жозеп опускає Один зі своїх
приладів Він показує що на глубині 30 МТ
температура води приблизно 16гра зацельс
паскуаль каже що поверхня моря
потеплішала на цілий градус відтоді як
він почав проводити
вимірювання це викликає занепокоєння
тому що підвищення температури
призводить до того що вода розширюється
А разом із цим підвищується і рівень
моря
ми бачимо це і на
пляжах щороку вони стоють на півметра
вужчими я це
перевірив з 1993 року пляж тут зменшився
на 15
мтів разом із температурою паскуаль
вимірює в міст солі у
воді надаючи вкрай важливу інформацію на
яку покладаються такі рибалки як Ісаак
моя
наша робота тісно пов'язана з цими
даними Якби ми знали про все це трохи
більше як він ми були б кращими
рибалками Це
точно є види риб які не можуть впоратися
з підвищенням
температури а інші які звикли до
теплішої води тепер приходять на північ
з більш південних районів
жозеп паскуаль ретельно занотовує
координати і
виміри потім у місцевому туристичному
бюро він переносить дані на вебсайт яким
користуються науковці з усього
світу НАСА побачили мої дані в
американському спеціалізованому журналі
і порівняли їх зі своїми власними
результатами Вони сказали що тепер
знають що їхні супутникові прилади
працюють
правильно
багаторічна колекція даних паскуаля
справила враження І в
Барселоні в інституті морських наук
дослідники вивчають як зміна клімату
впливає на рослин тварин і на
людей особливо страждає Арктика каже
океанограф джорді салат але також і
Середземне
море ми спостерігаємо більші зміни на
поверхні води ніж в інших морях світу є
регіони якіми ваємо гарячими точками і
Середземне море одна з таких точок
хобі паскуаля набуло особливого значення
в епоху кліматичних змін саме тому його
місія продовжувати проводити виміри і
робити свій внесок у сповільнення
глобального
потепління це боляче тому що це не
природ процес Ви можете бачити як Все
змінюється як ми це змінюємо усе
взаємопов'язано навіть якщо якась
маленька частина дестабілізується все
виходить з
рівноваги жозеп паскуаль не має дітей
але сподівається знайти когось хто
продовжить його справу однак Він планує
продовжувати виходити в море і проводити
своє вимірювання так довго як тільки
зможе
так ось це дух багатолітніх людей у
Європі ведуть доволі ізольоване життя
частково тому що їхні сім'ї живуть
далеко від них а соціальні заходи часто
розраховані більше на молоду
аудиторію у Швеції Мадлен монсон не
захотіла миритися з самотністю тому
вирішила взяти справу в свої руки і
створила простір де люди яким за 50
можуть веселитися і відриватися як у
старі добрі часи
[музика]
коли грає музика Мадлен монсон не може в
сидіти на місці 79тирічна шведка співає
і танцює поки крутить платівки для своїх
гостей дві ліві ноги тут не виправдання
Мадлен піднімає на ноги всіх і змушує
танцювати Я люблю музику і якщо я можу
зробити інших людей щасливими це чудово
Це саме те чого тут не вистачало колишня
модель і фітнес-тренерка Мадлен монсон
має яскраве минуле Але незважаючи на
різні місця роботи та етапи життя одне
залишилося незмінним її любов до
музики про те щоразу коли вона хотіла
танцювати вона стикалася з однією і тією
ж
проблемою я не могла нікуди піти
потанцювати мені доводилося стояти в
черзі із 20тирічними а в клубах усе
починається тільки об 11й вечора коли я
вже хочу лягати спати
так Мадлен монсон зробила з необхідності
чесноту і сама стала
діджейкою її дискотека відчиняє свої
двері о 18й для всіх кому 50 і більше
молодшим сюди
зась гості випивають щоб розігрітися
перед початком вечірки потім Мадлен дає
зрозуміти що час взути танцювальне
взуття я крутитиму платвки 4 години
поспіль Отже ви можете танцювати 4
години посі
просто прийміть це після цього ви підете
додому щасливими із 20 я кроків на ваших
крокомірах її підбадьорлива промова явно
працює навіть попри те що шведи мають
репутацію доволі стриманих людей тут
вони дають волю своїм
емоціям Нам потрібні такі
місця це наша музика і наш
час танцпол пере
че музика також допомогла Мадлен монсон
впоратися з горем коли багато років тому
помер її
[музика]
чоловік вона каже що хоч їй і було сумно
вона зібралася з духом і почала все
спочатку як
діджейка мені багато чого вдається але
не все треба наважитися спробувати Нехай
навіть і не вдасться треба просто
набратися сміливості що найгіршого
[музика]
Мадлен скоро виповниться 80 років але ця
жвава пенсіонерка не планує припиняти
займатися діджеїнгом вона надто зайнята
вирішуючи який улюблений трек увімкнути
наступним яка енергія і яке ставлення до
життя а на цьому Ми завершуємо
сьогоднішній випуск Європа У фокусі
Приєднуйтесь до нас наступного тижня щоб
дізнатися більше історій із усієї
Європи
than